hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday December 10th 2019 what's going
on how are you how you doing you're
doing good that's good
I'm not I hope you are I'm not you know
I was gonna try to tough my way through
this podcast and smile and act like
everything's [ __ ] rosy oh Jesus
Christ
it just never [ __ ] ends they never
rinse never [ __ ] ends the work never
[ __ ] ends and on top of that I sat
down I watched some sports this weekend
let's get it out of the way oh how many
you dolphin fans left the sports bar be
honest how many you went out into the
kitchen and heard your one loyal friend
still in front of the TV going oh my god
right and then you ran back in like what
happened what happened jesus [ __ ]
christ that last play of that game that
live you know what that highlight looked
like not the first guy who caught it the
set with a guy latter led to that
literally looked like you know when you
see an NFL great and then you look at
one of his high school highlights
specifically the running backs you ever
notice it's like this 20 people on the
other team it seems all standing around
he just runs past all of them and you're
like why did they just tackle him oh cuz
he's an NFL guy playing against high
school football players that happened
against my team I felt bad for Gronk he
was obviously in there because they
thought they were gonna throw a Hail
Mary rather than like a [ __ ] 15 20
yard pass congratulations to the dolphin
she [ __ ] Onis in Miami Patriots now
nine and four I think it's a foregone
conclusion that the road to the circlet
balls now so can you circuit it's gonna
be a fun playoff
not for Patriots fans not the way our
[ __ ] defense was playing yesterday
jeez Tom Brady once again once again his
dilemma how many [ __ ] points do I
have to score how many times do I got to
put on the white hat gallop into town
and [ __ ] save all the damsels in
distress' how many times like he looked
[ __ ] unbelievable absolutely shredded
the Dolphins defense and once again
comes away with a loss I would love to
see he has to have the record all-time
record for passing yards in a loss 500
yards 300 yards 40 yards it's [ __ ]
nearly four touchdowns five five three
touchdown five touchdowns it doesn't
make a difference in this age of no
[ __ ] defense I'll tell you defense is
so bad they they got caught playing
safety Jesus Christ there was so many
times in that game where we could have
put him away and we didn't so but you
know it is it's a transitional year we
lost our best running back to wide
receivers a left tackle in a cornerback
and you know it takes a while for people
all to get on the same page you never
deli they're not least on the last play
of the game Jesus Christ
how do those guys even look at Tom Brady
you know when you [ __ ] do something
like that
Gronk was probably they hate not for
nothing I did catch one for you today
Tom time just [ __ ] players Adam
Wright he's he puts on his Uggs [ __ ]
brutal bronze went back-to-back huh how
about that [ __ ] that guy up there
Hyman hitting Charlie McAvoy I missed
the game because I've been out going to
these [ __ ] Christmas parties and [ __ ]
out here still haven't drank still have
not drank [ __ ] 15 days and feel good
about myself
[ __ ] thousand one thousand two bow I
mean McEvoy I think that was his first
game back but either way we're winning
games when it games with the new coach
and all that and I'm hoping I'm gonna
actually get some time I follow him on
Twitter
watch the highlights and [ __ ] so I know
what's going on beat Ottawa tonight 2-1
and overtime I don't know I'm just
trying to spend time with the family
baby she been having a great time one of
my relatives bought this motorized car
for my daughter in it she liked it the
first day and then I don't know what
happened I think she pushed the button
and ran over a little foot you know and
then she's kind of like what's with this
thing so she kind of stayed away from it
so finally tonight I just got on the
thing at the risk of breaking it I was
just going up and down the hallway going
away finally she wanted to get on it and
then all of a sudden that now she
doesn't want to get off it it was pretty
awesome she doesn't get steering or
stopping yet but I just sort of you know
I just sort of run along with the you
know bent at the waist for maximum
[ __ ] up of my dad back you know what
I mean
I'm telling if your dad you got to get
one of those foam rollers every night
and every morning I'm just on the floor
rolling out my back it's great it's
great sometimes in the middle of the day
but I must have like 40 minutes running
around like [ __ ] Igor in Frankenstein
like literally a 90 degrees bent at the
waist to trying running behind her
trying to steer this thing so she
wouldn't drive into chairs and
countertops and all of this [ __ ] and
then when she was finally done I went to
stand up and I just did though but it
was worth it cuz that's my buddy I also
watched liver Liverpool verse barn mouth
bo you are any mo you th told you I was
going to start watching them Jesus
Christ most Salif four goals does that
ever happen I felt like I was watching
some Wayne Gretzky [ __ ] every time I
watch that guy other than the World Cup
didn't go so well for Egypt there but
he's
a bunch of goals and I really enjoyed it
and I got to tell you it's raining out
once again and I had this ridiculous
urge to start drinking some Guinness
with some [ __ ] shots of Jameson and
I'm just like you know it's weird
everything about Great Britain Ireland
anything over there just makes me want
to drink because I think those are the
movies that I see you know baekje
blindest
don't know nothing about no robbery
right all they do is booze on that show
when they're not throwing their little
sharp hats at people you know Ireland is
[ __ ] Ireland you know Scotland you
know they're up there drinking that
[ __ ] pint are looking beer just you
know it's always raining what do you
want to do when you're training up you
know you want to start boozing but uh
really [ __ ] [ __ ] defense in that game
huh I don't know what I finally
understood I'm starting to stand
offsides a little bit more I guess I get
it because the goal is so big you can't
have people just running all around be
[ __ ] great if you could though I
think what the thing that I would have
just on if I was if I was to buy into a
soccer league here in America I would
make the goal smaller and then I would
just have a blue line in hockey and once
she got into the zone whoever was the
fastest [ __ ]
could get out front you know he just
make the goal a little bit smaller
somewhere between soccer size goal and
highlight you know somewhere in there
bigger than an NHL goal obviously it's a
giant [ __ ] ball sorry I'm recording
this late at night
I gotta I gotta be up with the kid
tomorrow morning so I gotta do this but
uh I really enjoyed it now what's the
next game what's the next game we have
out there in [ __ ] Premier League
let's see here Liverpool you [ __ ]
Liverpool football schedule come on come
on there we go bump up up ah dudududud I
thought they had another game this one -
twelve nineteen I need 1218 I definitely
want to see that man United game because
I know they're like the [ __ ] Yankees
oh we Liverpool versus a Polly this is
gonna be another one of these these
football clubs with the really small
stadiums it makes me feel guilty for
rooting for Liverpool to see somebody
with one of those cute little stadiums
alike oh yeah I got a root for these
guys it's like the Kansas City Royals
are the [ __ ] Premier League and they
got Man United then they then they up
against wolves just not I don't that
does not ring a bell is that one of
those little a stadium clubs or is that
gonna be one of those [ __ ] Illuminati
Freemasons up in it's got a creepy logo
and kind of like it New Castle's
Newcastle right that's a bigger place
Arsenal's Arsenal I know those are the
bigger ones right I think it's a big
gauge man United in ourself I recognise
them 12 16 and 12 29 I'll be watching
those games you know if I'm allowed to
from allowed to you know you know it's a
guy you don't call the [ __ ] shots do
you know you do not you know jeez what a
[ __ ] weird Nast on a weird week it's
just sort of a normal week now you know
people digging back into people's tweets
yeah you [ __ ] said them when you said
this back when you that you were this
person that you no longer are remember
when you [ __ ] did that and then
somebody else comes along or what about
these people they [ __ ] did that and
then the whole world is like well they
have vaginas so it doesn't count I saw
this [ __ ] lady lady former Miss
Kentucky said naked pictures to a 15
year old student yeah you watch the slap
on the wrist she gets that's how it
works that's the world we live in
they're victims and they never get
punished for some reason I just don't
understand it I thought we were going
for equality here it's like if you [ __ ]
up you [ __ ] up right everybody gets
[ __ ]
this same [ __ ] pound of flesh taken
no is that how it works
I don't know how it works all I know is
now is I'm feeling like this is like
it's gonna become a world where it's
just like I you know I'll kind of do
that job but I don't
be the guy doing the job job I'll be on
the outskirts of the guy doing the job
because I'm not gonna you know you know
people just I know this whole [ __ ]
world now we're like people are just oh
that guy's successful or she's
successful let's go back and let's try
to [ __ ] ruin whatever they're doing I
think if you [ __ ] do that someone
should go back into your life interview
a bunch of people and let's see if
you're a good [ __ ] person cuz if
you're not I mean what the [ __ ] going
on then you just being a [ __ ] you just
upset because somebody else has
something that you don't is that what it
is I don't know
anyways so today I went to this awesome
birthday party it's a friend of ours so
we go over there my lovely wife and my
beautiful daughter right and it's like a
two-year-old birthday so we [ __ ] go
over there and we're having a great time
and then there's one big kid there she's
like six years old she's like the older
sister or somebody or whatever and she's
got like this giant like that like
dollhouse it's like a I got tree fort
but it's on the ground you know it's
like a doll house that a kid can go into
the [ __ ] he called that clubhouse I
don't know what it is right so she's in
there and in the dude like whose
daughter was hooked that up had like a
doorbell it had a sign with with the six
year old girl's name on it in a little
phone jack thing in there I mean this
thing was was awesome so she was in
there and she was like preparing
breakfast or whatever and oh my god did
I bomb in front of this six-year-old
every time I went left I should have
went right right it was hilarious like I
sat down I was standing like watching my
daughter going in and out of the doors
right and then she announces she goes I
made pine cones for breakfast so I see
this little seat that you sit outside
almost like a firt serving window so I
sat down I said oh I go thank thank you
very much for making me a pineco she
goes I didn't give it to you yet and I
went oh [ __ ] sorry
so then she hands it to me and I go
thank you I go how much is that
and she goes it's not for sale because
they're not for sale I was like oh all
right sorry I thought it just struck me
as like a little lemonade stand thinking
sighs all right and then she looks at me
and she goes is 1250 so then I pretend
to count out $12.50 and she goes no
that's not what it cost she goes that's
what time it is it's just like all
righty then I'm gonna leave cuz
evidently I have the intellect of a
three-year-old because you're destroying
me she got me three times in a row thank
you for making me for the pinecone she
goes I didn't give it to you yet how
much do I owe you
it's not for sale it's 1250 age of 1250
that's not the price it's the time I was
just like wow this takes me back to when
I was in school whatever I said was just
was just it just I don't know but
anyways I still had a great time you
know a daughter figuring out some stuff
you know how to go down the slide and
all that stuff and you know kids they
kind of go through this thing where in
the beginning they're like really
outgoing at least my daughter was and
then they get shy and then you know we
got her to be outgoing again so it's
kind of cool
watching her do that and I was you know
it's kind of cool cuz I was like and I
was in the valley area kind of out by
Van Nuys Airport and just the way the
wind was blowing you know the planes
were taken off till like I guess I don't
know if it was the north but sort of no
not towards LAX they were headed the
other way and they're kind of going over
the house which I thought was awesome
and then I looked in the alley and there
was a guy with like this one floor house
and he had a windsock on top of his on
top of his roof and I'm thinking like is
that guy like a pilot like why like who
the [ __ ] could see that from the air but
in a way it was kind of cool that he was
doing it maybe he's a pilot and he goes
out and just because he takes off from
there and it's kind of a straight shot
down to the
poor he just sort of looks at it but
then he could just listed the [ __ ]
hey this anyways to know which way he's
gonna take off I don't know I just never
seen a windsock on top of anything other
than a skyscraper or at least someone
would like a helipad on it those you you
know don't wanna talk about it just
basically shows which way the winds
blowing and you always take off and land
into the wind for optimal performance
and the last thing you do is you don't
want to have it at your back that's not
a good thing anyways but we were driving
up there and it's just like I always
knew people drove crazy I don't like
driving on the highway with my kid
I just don't people out here if anybody
out here is listening in LA you know I
know this isn't gonna make a difference
because there's so many of you guys out
here but like that [ __ ] [ __ ] will you
pass people on the right-hand side you
really gotta be key you're gonna [ __ ]
kill somebody you know you passed
somebody on the left the further left
you go the faster you go alright the
furthest left that you can go that's the
people driving the fastest you don't
drive that fast in the first [ __ ]
lane somebody's trying to get off the
highway they're making their way over
now all of a sudden you got to be going
like 80 miles an hour to get off the
[ __ ] highway what are you doing I
just think it's because there's there's
so many lanes it's like six lanes out
here on either side that I think all the
routes just becomes I don't know what it
is and there's so much traffic I just
feel like people are just like oh my god
an open [ __ ] lane I can go a quarter
of a mile and not have to hit the brakes
and they just they just [ __ ] slam the
gas down whatever the hell it is they're
doing but it's really unsettling and
then I'm sitting there with a I don't
want to [ __ ] snap and I can't because
my kids in the car cuz I don't want to
[ __ ] be that guy I don't know dude
but anyways I'm doing some benefits out
here this week I believe Thursday night
I'm gonna be up at the Ice House and on
then I'm also doing one at the the Fonda
Theatre for
for who the hell is it for the Comedy
Store so that's what I'm doing this week
and I got a couple of those things I
mean I got to be doing I'm trying to
take some time off before I go to Europe
but I also have to be on my game if when
I go to Europe so it's sort of a
slippery slope but I got a bunch of new
[ __ ]
that I want to talk about I can't wait
to talk about it get on stage here
tomorrow night I think I'm gonna head
out somewhere here in LA and try to get
on some stage time get some stage time I
should say and I still have not fixed my
headphone jack here but I am done
flipping out about it because I'm trying
to be a better man anyway so when
somebody gives so when some woman gives
a speech at an awards show I can sit
there nodding like yes I did the work
I've done the work I understand now
simply safe everybody make sure nothing
becomes make sure nothing comes between
you and protecting your family this
holiday and save hundreds of dollars
while you're at it with simply faith
home security if a storm takes out your
power simply safe is ready if an
intruder cuts your phone line simply
safe is ready say they destroy your
keypad or siren simply safe will still
get you the help you need these guys are
like the Terminator nothing stops them
maybe it's overkill maybe it's the last
thing you want to think about this
holiday but with simply safe you're
always ready simply safe believes
nothing should be should get between you
and protecting your family that's why
they only charge you what's fair what's
right $14.99 a month no contracts no
markups it's easy to install you'll have
your system up and running in just
minutes and today you can save hundreds
of dollars on that protection if you go
to a simply safe birth calm that simply
safe bird calm but hurry this holidays
offer offers ending soon simply safe /
calm that's a great thing to get because
everybody knows you everybody knows this
next you know realists this
[ __ ] real estate bubbles gonna burst
these stupid luxury high-rise apartment
that every politician is letting go
through just build it up it's good gives
people jobs just keep going it's all our
money put it out there put it out there
over build make more than what is needed
I mean out here in LA I swear to god
it's like every other block they're just
knocking [ __ ] down and then putting up a
luxury high-rise apartment and they're
forcing like you know they're forcing
people out and I don't know where
they're gonna find all of these rich
people it's that [ __ ] they're like seems
to me that's like for the the upper 10%
of people and it's a hundred percent of
the buildings that seem to be getting
built out here I don't know but the [ __ ]
do I know I'm just a goddamn comedian
but I would invest in simply safe
because there's gonna be a bunch of
[ __ ] homeless people trying to break
into your house oh but oh do me on DS me
undies get [ __ ] simply safe to do to
me undies me on the
Danya safe and that is great get some
barbed wire and a [ __ ] BB gun you
sleep during the day you shoot and have
fun when the guy sticks his head through
your [ __ ] screen window with you
[ __ ] velvet balls in his face you're
really comfortable me undies the coveted
micro motile modal fabric which is three
times softer than cotton you've never
felt this fabric keep get ready to
experience pure bliss and underwear form
you can also get a style that is
perfectly suited for you or that special
someone men and women can each choose
from four different cuts all of which
are available from classic colors too
adventurous prints seriously these fun
undies yawning crazy here these fun
undies would be a great stocking stuffer
but why stop at undies me undies has
cozy lounge pants and Wendy's in that
same supersoft fabric perfect for
wearing Christmas morning my undies has
a great offer from my listeners for any
first-time purchasers when you purchase
any me undies you get 15% off and free
shipping order by 1216 for free shipping
in time for Christmas crunch for time
you can't go wrong with the me undies
gift card this is a no-brainer get 15%
off a pair of the most comfortable
undies you will ever put on to get your
15% off your first pair free shipping
and 100% satisfaction guaranteed go to
me undies calm / 4 that's me andis calm
/ / o lastly but not leastly what is
this here
stamps.com talk about how the holidays
are always the busiest time of year it
absolutely is everybody's got to go out
shopping whether they like it or not
what do you have on your holiday list I
still have this [ __ ] headphone phone
jack whatever the [ __ ] you call it when
I learned what it is then I feel like I
can order it you know as opposed to just
ordering a bunch of [ __ ] that sort of
looks like it is it a jack is that an
adapter I don't know what it is what
else do I have on my list I don't know
hey everyone what's the final I know I
have something we wish you a Merry
Christmas cuz it's cold outside baby
it's cold outside what do I have fur
what does my wish for Christmas I wish
that all of you guys have a very Merry
Christmas and that they don't trying to
take any music away from you you know
they're gonna start with that song and I
figured about three months they're gonna
go after Aerosmith for Walk This Way you
know she could walk up whatever way she
wants to maybe a couple of books I'm
reading a book right now Bob Cousy and
Bill Russell that I'm really enjoy I'm
Toni we can get back to books I keep
threatening that I'm gonna go back to
church I'm gonna start reading books
that I'm gonna go back to church then
I'm gonna start burning the books that
I'm reading and then I'm gonna go to a
remote island and get shot with bows and
arrows that's how I'm gonna go out
that's that's a-that's on my Christmas
list anyways how many errands do you
have to run I got a couple more how is
stamps calm helping you save time this
holiday season well once I buy the [ __ ]
I don't have to go to the post office I
could just mail it from my house you
know anyways as you know the holidays
are the busiest time of year especially
at the post office that's why you use
stamps calm it saved so much time during
the hectic holiday season use stamps top
calm to send all your gifts out it's
perfect wrap them up send them out see
you later
and right now you too can enjoy the
stamps.com service with a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale without long
term commitments go to stamps comm click
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in bur that stamps.com
enter bur you know I really wonder how
to [ __ ] these guys I don't know
everybody's screaming and yelling about
[ __ ] that's in people's Twitter feeds
and meanwhile the bankers are about
ready to [ __ ] [ __ ] over another
generation of retirees and once again
they will not go to jail you know what I
mean and I gotta [ __ ] sit here and
listen about gender-neutral bathrooms
you know do you know what all you guys
have in your house or your apartment you
know what you already have you have a
gender-neutral a [ __ ] bathroom as
long as you got to sit down toilet I
mean that pretty much covers the entire
spectrum of way a human being can go to
the bathroom you know but I want to
meanwhile they're building another
luxury high-rise apartment with [ __ ]
old people's money our money and I will
live long enough to [ __ ] get out of
it I don't know what the [ __ ] would do
it what we need to do man is we need to
legalize weed at a federal level and we
need to export it and we need to get the
world high so they like us again and
then we take all that money we pay for
this never-ending war and then meanwhile
we get on to some sort of [ __ ]
electrical and solar power even though
at the end of the day it's probably not
cleaner but what it will do is put all
these [ __ ] people out of business
because they won't have any oil money to
pay why don't we do that and everybody
will be having a holly jolly Christmas
it's the best time of the year boo boo
to be food OOP I don't know if there'll
be snow let it sing you guys some carols
but a backup of cheer all right I bet
that we got some good emails this week
I have no idea whoa
oh I want to thank Rich Eisen by the way
for having me on his show I had a great
time man he's such a good dude just a
really good [ __ ] person and you know
all the people that are over there
hilarious I had such a fun time on that
show you know they were saying how Peter
was you know was raining crazy that day
and and I guess they got some sort of
warning where they were saying you know
Peter was saying you know you shouldn't
say it's raining cats and dogs any more
because if they actually were falling
out of the sky from a rain cloud
they'd get hurt and it's just like yeah
well we understand gravity but that's
never happened okay so of course I went
in there how do you not you know it's
like Jesus Christ it's raining cats and
dogs out there it's a frog strengthen
our moose out there and I love animals
you know I love animals as much as I
hate pushy [ __ ] yeah pushy [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right Wikipedia searching hey you
sweet Billy boy wanted to give you a
hand with your search engine always
using Wikipedia Oh
god bless you if you use Firefox or
Chrome there's a setting and the options
of course I don't or settings Chrome for
choosing the default search engine is
when you type in your location bar oh
wait a second well let me see all right
well I'm on Safari
let's see preferences all right here we
go
page 100% zoom never use font size
smaller than 9 the internet plugins show
menu change settings style sheet nothing
selected am I gonna [ __ ] this whole
thing up all right obviously this isn't
alright tabs general passwords
privacy's notifications advanced their
windows new tabs homepage
is apple.com oh I can change that I know
I could do that um remove history Jesus
Christ
search Oh search here we go search
engine is Google all right
oh where the [ __ ] the God am i you
[ __ ]
and they never works why why would it
work for me alright well that was a big
swing and a Miss bookmarks develop
window I have no idea everybody if
you're listening it says Safari then it
says file edit view history bookmark
develop window help I'm not going in to
help I've done that too many times I
[ __ ] asked a question and it never
answers the question that I [ __ ]
asked you know I've just been hurt too
many times do you know what I mean do
you know what I mean it's just one of
those things
all right the first known decorated tree
oh Christmas tree oh Christmas tree how
lovely are your branches you [ __ ]
there you're really a shrub in a month
you'll be a nub because you won't get
water then you go out in the trash it's
like a puppy mill for trees Oh Christmas
tree
lyrics let's see here well let's take me
to Wikipedia okay it's old Christmas
tree o Christmas tree
a lovely are thy branches that Jesus
someone with a powdered wig wrote this
one o Christmas tree o Christmas tree
just felt the letter O not o H how
lovely are thy branches bed Franklin is
a [ __ ] drunk Paul Revere beaches
horse Oh Chris smell these original
lyrics no your bows so your bow so green
and summertime stay brave
we green in wintertime Oh Tannenbaum Oh
Christmas tree how lovely are though I
don't know what a beau is I don't want
to Tannenbaum that's like a rich
person's last name mr. Teddy balm I
presume
right now I gotta look like a few what a
Tannenbaum it's not let's just start
[ __ ] singing about it that's when you
know you're into the holidays when you
know what all this [ __ ] [ __ ] means
you know those Martha Stewart type
chicks you know the fangirls that really
like keep up but they'll know how to
make a Tannenbaum o Tannenbaum is a
German Christmas song based on a
traditional eyes and what I want
Wikipedia [ __ ] intrusive [ __ ] Oh
Tana Baugus it's all one thing o
Tannenbaum oh wait did they write o
Christmas tree I guess all that means
all that means tree in German oh [ __ ]
when I go to Germany next month I'm not
to sing that to all those [ __ ] kraut
eating sons of [ __ ] over they oh oh
Tainan bomb won't die in a bomb there's
a German Christmas song based on a
traditional folk song it became
associated with the traditional
Christmas tree by the early 1920s and
sung as a Christmas carol the modern
lyrics were written in 1824 by Leipziger
by the leap Zig organist teacher and
composer Ernst awesome shush a
Tannenbaum is a fir tree the lyrics do
not exactly actually referred to
Christmas tree or describe a decorate
Christmas tree instead they referred to
the first evergreen quality as a symbol
of constancy and faithfulness oh I see
this guy was alone in the woods started
having [ __ ] feelings about a tree you
know what I mean yet we still complain
in this country crisis people in Germany
writing songs about trees well I guess
we have tree huggers here
you know eventually whoever the PETA is
for trees who's that [ __ ] Greenpeace
you know they're not gonna like the
expression tree hugger because the tree
has no say in that physical contact so
in a way it's a form of assault
all right the first known decorated
Christmas tree dear Billy ghost of
Christmas past I really do look like
that don't I did you know that on your
tour of Europe you'll be stopping in the
city where the oldest recorded
decorating of a Christmas tree went down
I didn't know that riga or riga latvia
that almost sounds like two characters
on [ __ ] taxi riga and latke riga
latvia heard a friend talking about it
immediately thought of you what's your
favorite way to decorate a tree quickly
without my wife in the room telling me
I'm doing it wrong what else I don't
know I I my favorite way to decorate
tree would be with my lovely wife with
some eggnog with some Christmas music on
a little booze in the eggnog we do a
little slow dance I kiss her under a
mistletoe you know one of the last year
she can do that because that's a major
crisis for white women that you know
that there's mistletoe out there I guess
you know they really have a lot of
problems and that's like one of the ones
right on the top of the list you know I
mean forget about climate change and
that swirl of trash in in the Pacific
Ocean can't even say I think what we
need to get down to first off is what's
the deal with mistletoe
anyways I when you have camel
so during the hosel holidays is that
called mistletoe reverse mistletoe
upside-down inverted mistletoe I don't
know when I was a kid we made ornaments
in school with macaroni yeah then you'd
spray-painted gold macaroni glitter and
white glue and [ __ ] like that
I doubt that they do that anymore thanks
and love to you and the family and the
mmm Photoshop guy who lets me see you
and all your imaginary glory yeah we
used to always used to be a thing like I
made you know yeah I used to make
ornaments I remember there was one it's
like it took a coffee cup and then some
one of those pipe cleaner things you
know you cut a hole in the bottom of the
cup and you I know somehow you ran a
piece of macaroni and it was opposed to
look like a bell and the top of the pipe
cleaner coming through was they handle
then they then they would make a
cardboard cutout of a little or paper
cutout of a Christmas tree then you put
a bunch of macaroni on it for whatever
reason macaroni was a big deal he'd glue
it to the paper and then he'd
spray-painted gold and then he'd give it
to your mother and she'd look at it like
that is the ugliest [ __ ] thing I've
ever seen but my kid made it and I love
my kids so that will now go on the
[ __ ] front door until you're 47 yeah
I don't know I'm not you know I like
ornaments I wish we had a lot more of
them but like I don't like those
Christmas tree shops they creep me out
and like really people that that go in
there are weird in a way that I'm not
weird and well however they are weird is
it just [ __ ] with my weird and I get I
get all weirded out man and I just [ __ ]
I just leave I can't do that you know
I'm trying to get to the point where I'm
not saying they're a bunch of [ __ ]
weirdos in there cuz I know I'm I'm
weird right but I go in there and it's
like you know plus I don't like clutter
and I don't like a bunch of [ __ ] around
my house you know what I mean it's like
those people that like you go by
somebody's house
and every year they have like you know
those figurines and [ __ ] that they put
in the front yard and every year you see
the same ones and then they add a few
more have you ever thought about like
way the [ __ ] do they put those things
the other 11 months of the year like how
much of that of their garage is that
thing like it's the middle of July it's
hot as [ __ ] you're going in there you're
trying to find the cooler and then
you're walking by like reindeer and
snowmen and all that that's just that's
just it's too [ __ ] weird for me you
know I don't step over that [ __ ] all
right I do we just have like we just
have the Christmas tree lights and then
we just put the bulbs on it and I put
him on the tree and my wife stands back
and she well this year she did it that
way you know she always decorated in
other years this year we got the kids so
she was just kind of holding her and
telling me there's too many blue ones
there you need a little more red and
then put some green over there and uh
you know so that was that I probably
would enjoyed that more if I was boozing
I'm not gonna lie to you but uh but I
didn't I wasn't I've been drinking my
eggnog straight this year with a little
shot of nutmeg and if I sound bored
shitless I am it's this time of night
it's 9:00 10:00 at night this is the
time of night where usually you know I'm
having a good time and I just don't
anymore but I will tell you in the
morning it's the best thing about being
sober it's the [ __ ] morning you know
you wake up you feel like a [ __ ]
million bucks and yeah I don't know
anyways this is always a weird time here
I love the holidays and it's also
depressing that another [ __ ] year
went by but then the second it's January
first I'm like it's all ahead of me I'm
gonna make those changes I'm gonna
become a better person if air if air why
not by sea dear Billy frisbee frown I
don't even know what that means I don't
want to know what that means I don't
know I don't know
I don't need to know that my frown is
weird too I already have enough physical
[ __ ] hang-ups frisbee frown bill I'm
I'm a little behind in the podcast since
I watched my one year old girl full time
oh yeah but you hit the lottery they're
the best
and after sensor what I play in my house
now yeah I mean I understand that he
says a little while ago you were
explaining that you choose not to go
into the ocean saying that it's an
unnecessary risk and basically that we
don't belong in there compared to the
other animals that do belong I don't
disagree with you okay but I am just
wondering by that logic how you justify
going after your pilot's license license
or whatever it takes to fly your
whirlybirds and the like I was hoping
you would compare this while you were
talking about it but I don't think you
ever did obviously as humans we take a
lot of crazy risks every day like just
getting in a car and going 70 miles per
hour per hour yeah I know and doing that
in the left-hand Lane and all it takes
is one [ __ ] [ __ ] on the other side
you ever see that [ __ ] or where the
[ __ ] 18-wheeler jackknifes and comes
over on the other side you know I got
the kid in the car now so I try to stay
in the right lane but everybody's doing
90 miles an hour out here in it okay
anyways but I would like I would think
the pilot thing would fall under the
same category is taking a swim on the
beach thanks as always for the great
podcast my wife always knows if I have
you on my headphones by the stupid grin
on my face go [ __ ] yourself
great question sir well the reason why I
got a pilot's license was because I read
up on the banking system and realized
that it was a giant Ponzi scheme and I
was afraid because of how dysfunctional
the city that I live in is you know you
can barely get out of it when everybody
when it's all working forget about if
the [ __ ] ever hit the fan how would I
get out of here and the only way I could
think was
to learn how to fly a helicopter get up
and get out now I I did the first part
of the plan now the major part of the
plan is to actually have access to a
helicopter close by you know that's why
I did it
and but I will tell ya it is a a you
know there is an element of danger to it
but now that I have my kid
I don't solo that much every once in a
while I do just to you know just to know
that I can do it but for the most part I
just I'll fly with an instructor and you
know I don't do anything crazy I don't
fly and like you know you know winds
beyond a certain amount of knots and I
also will tell you though it's way way
way way way safer than getting in a car
and going on the highway and I have
experienced both and I can tell you like
you know there's nobody up there I mean
there is but you know what I mean but
there isn't and it's like we're talking
to each other we're in the same airspace
and we're announcing our position and
where we're at okay and if we don't see
each other then you take offensive moves
I guess a defensive move you're
proactive like if the guys at the same
altitude you just tell them well okay
I'm going to ascend 200 feet or whatever
the [ __ ] you need to do and then even if
you don't see each other to the last
second you literally like hundreds of
feet above or below them and it's fine
there's no radio contract contact on the
highway and you are basically flying in
formation with people who are on meds
they're texting they didn't get enough
sleep they suck at driving
they don't abate maybe they're really
good at driving so they're driving like
a [ __ ] lunatic like everybody else is
as good as they are those people are
probably more even more dangerous and
someone just sucks at driving and drive
slow and there's a lot of times that
I've you know finished flying
flying solo and landed and got in my car
and within two miles of going down the
street I watched somebody just [ __ ]
t-boned somebody else somebody go flying
off a [ __ ] scooter and land on my
side of the [ __ ] Road and slide on
their face
somebody just driving in the left lane
and judge for whatever reason just veers
into the [ __ ] they were texting
weren't paying attention literally
slammed into the median between you know
both sides of the highway
fortunately stayed on this side of the
highway so they didn't you know go up
and over and kill somebody and literally
just went spinning 360 360 3 slike 5
360s across six lanes of traffic before
slam like a stock car accident nobody
near the guy just [ __ ] did I I see
that all of the time so I understand
what you're saying and I have to be
honest with you like it is an
unnecessary risk but I find it I most of
what I say about the oceans because I
have such a tremendous fear of it and I
just can't get over that all of this
[ __ ] is you know I'm treading water with
my head above it you know what I mean
and and everything else is like I don't
you ever go into a pit of poisonous
snakes and then bury your head in the
sand is that all just sort of [ __ ]
slither and pass you yeah and just
things can go down there's things down
there they can literally swallow you
whole or bite you in half and they are
you know what a thousand times faster
than you yeah I mean say what you want
about flying like I you know the
altitude I fly it like I know I can I
can still breathe I don't need any
assisted or a pressurized cabin or
anything like that this it's it's you
know I think you know you pick your
poison but I'll tell you like there's a
couple of things that I watch that just
you know literally make my palms sweat
one of them is cave diving
and if you ever want to just just you
know hear the most unbelievable story
ever
III forget that that fighters name he's
actually one of my favorite UFC fighters
what is his name cowboy something the
guy from like New Mexico
whatever he's just like that one of the
baddest dudes ever he caved eyes and he
was on the Joe Rogan experience
just look up Joe Rogan experience cave
diving and just listen to that [ __ ]
story and you're literally listening to
the guy that went through it so you you
know somehow he lives but still your
psyche I was literally sitting there you
know when you do that thing when you you
put your hands like over your nose in
your mouth just sitting there and your
index fingers are between your eyes I
was just sitting there like that just
covering my mouth just listening to this
[ __ ] story the guy literally said
that they have a rule down there
that when someone gets in trouble in a
cave dive you just leave them because
someone's going home someone's gonna
make it home because it's so [ __ ] up
down there that if you try to help that
person then both of you are gonna die
[Music]
that's kind of how it starts and then it
goes from there so anyways yeah cave
diving and then those people who do that
free climbing up skyscrapers and every
time you think they're up to they make
those [ __ ] videos and every time you
think they went up is high they're
literally on the [ __ ] radio tower and
they just keep going up and up and up
and up and up and it's just like I just
sit there like I don't know how the [ __ ]
anybody can do some [ __ ] like that so
maybe that's why I said most of what I
say I sawed jaws at a certain age and I
just never got over it I just never got
over I'm like I'm all [ __ ] set on
that
it's so crazy to me like you know that
would you ever go in you know into the
gym whatever is left of the jungle in
Africa with is just wild [ __ ]
hyenas and tigers and level lions and
[ __ ] hyenas and Hindi and God knows
[ __ ] what out there would you ever go
out there without a goddamn weapon okay
and then you go into the [ __ ] ocean
no guns work down there as far as I know
you know bet you're gonna have is that
stupid little [ __ ] bow and arrow
contraption
alright now I gotta look up underwater
gun is there an underwater gun you can
possibly [ __ ] have sort of [ __ ]
list is this gonna put me on underwater
firearm goddammit I'll tell you
something human beings don't ever want
to be where they can't [ __ ] kill
something are you [ __ ] kidding me
look at this thing
slow motion underwater guns
shark ammo Oh God
Jesus Christ that's all you need is some
[ __ ] people from Texas going there I
swear to god man one [ __ ] shark looks
at me one [ __ ] looks at me I'm
gonna [ __ ] blow its goddamn [ __ ]
fish brain out God made us in His image
and he will asked us to go forth and
multiply and blast a [ __ ] hammer head
right in his [ __ ] a head
I have to see this now slow motion
underwater guns
shark ammo alright you can skip this ad
in three two one
BAM here we go hey I'm a [ __ ] YouTube
guy I'm gonna [ __ ] tell you about
shark [ __ ] all right this guy's alright
he's trying out some of the badass guns
she could ever [ __ ] have he's
shooting watermelon good for him not
shooting any people here's the breakdown
right just get to the alright something
happen I [ __ ]
my recorder got full let's talk about
shooting sharks in the [ __ ] goddamn
face man I'm [ __ ] you Arnie oh I'll
give you another [ __ ] breathing hole
you [ __ ] whale face [ __ ] they
actually figured out how to do it they
got like a [ __ ] ak-47 but even then
do you think you're gonna be able to
whip that thing out fast enough not
Jesus Christ you know what I mean what
what are we doing the [ __ ] are we doing
we're underwater shooting [ __ ] guns
it's sharks I don't know I mean see sir
you know I got to tell you something
it's [ __ ] nuts as flying is when you
go fly you don't have to go up there
with a [ __ ] gun cuz something's gonna
eat you out of the goddamn sky
there's no [ __ ] bird of prey that's
gonna grab onto your whatever the [ __ ]
you're flying
anyways but thank you for listening to
the podcast buddy you know you are right
though I am a bit of a hypocrite but
like I said most of it is just me being
afraid of the ocean
gift list pressure bill my wife gets mad
that I don't tell her what I want for
Christmas or birthdays yeah well it's a
pain in the ass because then she has to
guess anyways obviously now the issue is
Christmas I told her I have everything I
need and like you I'm trying to thin out
all my junk it actually stresses me out
because I'm being led to feel bad for
not wanting to too gifted something to
be gifted something just asked her for
an experience just ask her you want to
go to a car show or something like that
something we can do together just do
that so she has something alright we
both make a lot of money and buy
whatever we want she doesn't need
anything either but gave me a cute idea
of something small I guess she's not a
total [ __ ] and just Jesus she's beating
she's not even remotely a [ __ ] that's
completely I would throw this on a
[ __ ] [ __ ] court if you even ever why
ugh why did you
I guess she's not a total [ __ ] I just
like and just wants to make me happy but
in a roundabout way it ruins the fun of
it sometimes how do you deal with this
yeah I usually just asked for an
experience there's usually some place I
want to go to like am i I'm a big fan of
[Music]
you know hamburger stand like greasy
spoon type places I don't like I'm not a
big fan of fancy [ __ ] restaurants I
mean I like going there whatever but
like I love going to like you know
there's a couple place a place out and
Bill's burgers I wanted to go to high
Roenick ly enough although I heard the
guy doesn't work there anymore but the
burgers are still tasty I love a great
taco truck food trucks I like doing like
[ __ ] like that I like going to car shows
and you know I went to a Christmas party
at this custom motorcycle shop the one
that Keanu Reeves bought into and went
down and just like I mean and that would
to me as an adult that was like
Christmas I went down there and they
were talking about how how they make the
parts by hand and how like a 1200 pound
slab of like aluminum will come in and
from that like ice sculptors except they
use it with the aluminum they make parts
for these absolutely gorgeous
motorcycles arch krch motorcycles and I
don't know like I think cuz I became
like a closet gearhead out here where I
don't know how to do any of that [ __ ]
but I could literally watch somebody
work on a car describe how they Derek
the car guy I'm a huge fan of his I you
know I love that [ __ ] so whatever the
hell you're into she loves you just gay
she wants to give you something Jesus
Christ it's like she's gonna buy you a
desk anyways you got me a bottle of
booze you like I don't know boxing hey
Billy bank-shot the third I've recently
been getting fitter thanks to training
sessions at
boxing gym good for you I wanted to test
myself and try some low-level legal of
course amateur boxing dude there's no
[ __ ] reason to get your bell rung for
no [ __ ] money when you're not gonna
try to pursue it as a professional and
be careful
now she goes my girlfriend won't allow
it good for her she likens me trying it
out to her trying out stripping in front
of a crowd and how against the idea and
how against that idea I'd be can't say
she's wrong do you reckon I should try a
couple of fights just to see if I like
it and not tell her or do I respect her
wishes and leave it as a question that
doesn't need to be answered sir I would
never tell you not to pursue your dreams
but I wouldn't do it
sneaking around I would at the very
least tell her that you're gonna do one
fight but you know what are you gonna
what if you go when you get you [ __ ]
nose broken and then you got to show up
and try to be like Luca alright my name
is Luca I live on a second floor I
walked into a [ __ ] door you don't
have to you don't have to do that right
I don't know I I yeah communication is
always the way to go with the woman is
what I've learned and I've learned and I
keep learning and you communicate with
them and through the communication
they'll with they'll end up telling you
how it's gonna go down because it always
goes down the way they want it to go
down and that's basically it and that's
basically it do what they say goes if
you want to stay with them and it's
brutally not [ __ ] fair but you're a
guy and nobody gives a [ __ ] so what I
would do if you're going to go ahead and
do with it anyways I would just I would
just tell her that you're gonna do it
it's something that you need to do
something you need to prove to yourself
or whatever the [ __ ] it is and I think
you know other than that keep moving
your head there buddy
overrated living in major cities is
there anything worse than a bunch of
losers thinking that if they live where
it's cool to live that they're cool to
oh dude you're preaching to the choir
here that's what I've done my entire
adult life and I am NOT cool they
completely deny the fact that living on
top of one another is frustrating and
unnatural New York smells like [ __ ]
la is overcrowded New York doesn't smell
like [ __ ] areas of it does New York
Manhattan is like a giant Bed Bath &
Beyond now la is definitely overcrowded
absolutely but I gotta be honest with
you though so where are you suggesting
to live because if you get to rural then
then it that just gets too [ __ ]
boring your food options a lot of
options you know you want to go see a
band and they're not gonna come anywhere
near you now you gotta jump in a car for
four [ __ ] hours
I definitely envy people who live in
wide open spaces and [ __ ] like that I
think it's really cool
and I got a lot of respect for people
that live out there like that but just
living where I've lived I don't know how
long I could do it I go a little [ __ ]
stir-crazy although there's a lot of
people here in LA that you know had that
second home and [ __ ] Wyoming or
whatever but my wife isn't gonna would
never go for that so and she makes the
decisions underrated living in midsize
cities oh here's his answer there's
nothing better than a city that's not
really a city you know I'd go at that
and I have my favorite ones and these
are all cities I wouldn't say they're
not cities but like I'm a big fan of
Milwaukee Chattanooga what else comes to
mind those are two of my favorites is
that it I think so I mean I enjoyed when
I was up in Idaho and in Montana
it just seems like nobody really [ __ ]
with you up there but then they have
like a massive meth problem so there's
always something there's always
something you know what I mean
I just wish with all the [ __ ] global
warming like that I just wish that those
people could still enjoy the climates
that they moved there for because you
know just growing up on the East Coast
and everything I think it's you know I
missed the four seasons and [ __ ] and I
also think it's really cool to kind of
live out in places like that you know
having said that you know the
experiences that I've gotten living in
LA this is one of my favorite cities and
I also love New York as much as I make
fun of both of these cities where else
you know I you know living in a sports
town today what's underrated 2fd move
away is going back and living in your
[ __ ] home state again you know and
you know if they could buy all the
[ __ ] sports packages just to watch a
regular-season game of your team that's
pretty [ __ ] over it - all right
that's the podcast for this week Merry
Christmas Happy Hanukkah oh Hanukkah is
going on right now happy Chanukah to
everybody and go [ __ ] yourselves and
I'll check in on you on Thursday